startups are a team based effort very  rarely do you see a startup done by a  single founder it happens but those are  corner cases  well you might see as the  name and bright lights of the founder is  best at getting pressed for himself or  herself but typically great startups are  teams and and the best teams are  complementary  they know how to work together they know  how to fight together they know how to  collaborate together  and they're all passionately driven to  the same goal that they've agreed to um  so so for me um not understanding that  you're putting together an orchestra  rather than playing a single instrument  and again to use the musical analogy  is where a lot of young entrepreneurs  get it wrong because let me remind you  and then  is that  entrepreneurship and founders  particularly founders are  almost never the smartest person in the  company their job is to have the  smartest people in the company working  for them  collaboratively as a team  you